le 7-8 sport bienvenue sur tv fils si
vous venez de nous rejoindre 26 minutes
pour faire le point sur l'actualité
sportive dans le département avec
anthony rech bonsoir anthony bonsoir ou
le fruit de mon soir à tous nous
parlerons cyclisme ce soir avec isabelle
gautheron ancienne championne de france
de cyclisme sur piste
vous êtes la marraine du vélo-club
d'elancourt 50 ans divine bonsoir à vous
bonsoir et tout d'abord nous allons
parler boxe éducative après les bons
résultats aux championnats régionaux
minimes du boxing de la verrière avec le
directeur sportif du club hassan aourid
bonsoir à vous bonsoir à vous alors tout
d'abord cantons ont préparé un peu
l'émission on suit évidemment les
résultats du club depuis plusieurs
saisons mais cette saison là précisément
les titres sont ramassées à la pelle
j'ai envie de dire ça ça réussit plutôt
bien
absolument donc en boxe éducative on est
de maintenant le premier club des
yvelines donc pas encore d'île de france
ça ne saurait tarder en tout cas
j'espère donc voilà on a neuf champions
départementaux
donc un benjamin cinq ans minimes
qu'attend cadets fera en cadets pardon
donc là un haut niveau ile de france
on a donc deux champions de france 1bis
champion de france d'ores et déjà minime
donc vous les voyez sur les photos
et ceux là sont qualifiés donc pour les
deux champions sont qualifiés pour les
interrégions qui dans le monde devrait
avoir lieu courant mars et vous êtes
satisfait de ce bilan complètement non
seulement
enfin moi je suis pas là que pour la
victoire je suis là aussi pour
l'éducatif et enfin est étonnamment pour
certains entraîneurs moi j'ai pris
beaucoup plus de plaisir avec les
perdants qu'avec les gagnants parce que
les perdants on fait vraiment des choses
magnifiques voilà oui mais ils vont
toujours des choses magnifiques
sauf qu'en général les perdants font
mieux qu'avant donc c'est cette journée
celle sur un c'est un pur bonheur
il progresse tout soit exact de
résultats le bilan est meilleur que la
saison passée absolument on était assis
champions départementaux l'année
dernière donc là on a on a fini en coire
voilà trois titres de plus
départementaux on a fini aussi haut
niveau régional à deux champions et un
vice-champion
sauf que là on encore les cadets qui
bossent qui boxe ce week end
et aussi on a un benjamin qui boxe a dit
me à domicile le 30 31 mars vous êtes
tous conviés à la verrière et alors
qu'est ce qui a fait que ce succès
grandissant c'est vos exigences qui
augmente c'est des pépites que vous
découvrez alors qu'est ce qui fait que
ça a marché
je pense la rigueur
la présence la gestion du stress parce
que voilà on nous fait un bond à percer
manche et d'un cursus beaucoup d'à tribe
bruit des enfants dans l'hymne à sion
dans le social tout ça donc voilà les
enfants si on leur met pas la pression
on leur fait comprendre que c'est un jeu
sa box et ça donne du résultat
automatiquement sans se prendre la tête
mais la rigueur vous détenez vous êtes
sévère avec véritable aussi ça rigole
c'est carré cé carré
non on rigole aussi on rigole mais je
veux dire c'est pas trop comment boulot
mais oui c'est vrai l'arrière fox et la
vie donc forcément il ya des règles pour
les respecter et donc ici prison pas
trop le choix il faut entrer mais sont
plutôt contents parce qu'ils ont débordé
mais doit être content je crois aussi ce
qui fait votre succès c'est votre
approche de la sau puisqu'on parle pas
de combat en sol chez ducati mais
dassault et vous avez une méthode un
petit peu particulière je crois est bas
alors la sauce qui le différencie du
combat c'est que c'est de la touche
la frappe est interdite alors sur sa
enfin mon club
si je peux me l'approprier donc notre
club est vraiment vraiment commence à
vraiment est réputé sur le respect du
règlement pour exemple on est parti en
picardie a terni exactement on a fait 9
face aux l'équivalent de neuf combats on
a neuf victoires
alors certains parce qu'ils sont doués
d'autres parce que juste il respecte le
règlement
voilà donc cesser c'est une
problématique à connaître quand on
respecte le règlement on a des chances
de gagner
cette rigueur qui fait le people soldes
succès à la salle en entraînement en
combat enfin en compétition
n'obligez gamins à respecter les règles
mais vous les voyez où après ces
différents gamin justement vous les
voyez évolué et comment on les voit
comment les voies dont ils sont restés
au club ils vont continuer ils vont
progresser faire cesser les combats par
la suite alors moi j'ai aussi un cursus
multisports aussi donc
moi j'estime flash je suis à fond dans
la boxe ne serait pas entraîneur de boxe
mais moi j'estime qu'un enfant il fait
ce qu'il aime
s'il se plaît dans la boxe il fait de la
boxe 6p dans le foot il fait du foot
l'essentiel c'est qu'ils se plaisent et
puis surtout qu'ils apprennent des
règles de vie vous parliez la de ce
système de comptabilisation des points
puisqu'il faut toucher n'ont pas frappé
ça c'est un aspect très compliqué à
faire comprendre aux jeunes parce que
quand on a 11 12 en a peut-être envie de
plus de ceux de se battre plus
franchement parallèlement vous en tenez
vous avez quelque chose à exprimer
non non non ça va bien ça va et vient
alors la veille de la guerre à la palud
être que ça soit même en compétition
même de boxe amateur de boxe
professionnelle ou une dans un sport
sport de combat certes mais on n'est pas
dans un bagarre donc déjà pour commencer
alors ce qui différencie l'assaut du
combat donc la boxe éducative de la boxe
amateur ou boxe professionnelle c'est
qu'on travaille sur des échanges donc un
échange remporté donne un point alors
qu'en boxe amateur un couperet fin un
coup donné avec une certaine puissance
avec une la bonne partie du point dans
la bonne zone de frappe
ça donne un point voilà la seule
différence c'est qu'on est allé change
et nous à chaque comporter comme en boxe
amateur
ce convoi traditionnelles voire dans les
médias il ya aussi notre clé de votre
réussite je crois c'est l'association
vous faites entre l'école et le sport
alors ça on y vient doucement ça c'est
des problèmes c'est que ça demande
beaucoup de temps on a pour tout vous
avouer on n'a pas beaucoup de problèmes
de discipline ni au niveau scolaire au
niveau des enfants qu'on a pourtant la
première année où je suis arrivé je
m'attendais à voir un peu plus de
problèmes la verrière cités sensibles
alors que pas du tout on a je les ai de
tête là deux enfants qui ont des
problèmes scolaires
effectivement on essaye de suivre et
justement leur donner des objectifs
comme ils s'accrochent aux sports leur
dire que c'est le sport c'est bien mais
ça sera pas possible si je travaille pas
l'école
voilà ça fonctionne pour l'instant ça
fonctionne pas il commence donc on y
pense
non là on commence à voir des
partenariats avec la réussite éducative
à la ville de la verrière
on commence à chercher à nouer des
partenariats avec le milieu scolaire
mais c'est vrai que ça demande beaucoup
de temps et nous on est aussi prôné
aussi occupé sur d'autres postes
ailleurs moi et les autres entraîneurs
parce que je suis pas tout seul et c'est
vrai que ça demande beaucoup de temps
mais dans l'idéal c'est ce qu'on
voudrait dire que vraiment le sport soit
associé à l'éducation jusqu'aux les
milieux scolaires ils sont plutôt
réceptifs à ce genre de demande parce
qu'on sait va y avoir une réforme du
temps scolaire d'organisation du temps
scolaire alors sans doute du temps libre
pour qu'éventuellement les associations
le prêt n'est en bénéficient il ya des
contacts avancés dans ce sens là pour
vous répondre je pense qu'il faudrait
les invités en tout cas nous avons été
sollicités au moins pour ça non pas du
tout mais non les preneurs parce que
vraiment on estime que bas le sport
c'est bien mais ça se lit pas tous enfin
moi je sais que dans mon cursus
d'animation j'ai eu beaucoup de jeunes
en général plus attirés par le foot qui
se met dans foot dans foot qui négligent
l'école et qui à la fin se retrouve sans
diplôme ou alors être pas grand chose et
qui c'est qui qui galèrent pour trouver
un emploi pendant ce léger ça veut dire
que dans votre système si on va jusqu'au
bout un jeune qui est dans votre club et
qui n'auraient pas de bons résultats
scolaires la fin de vers la fin d'année
scolaire en juin
comment ça se passe vous voulurent
conduisait sa licence ou pas déjà je
vous dirai en juin c'est un petit peu
tard déjà je pense qu'il faut s'y
prendre naples avance qu'au mois de juin
il redouble je pense non non le truc
c'est d'avoir un suivi sur enfin
régulier après faut pas se voiler la
face il ya des enfants qui sont plus
impliqués dans le sport qu'ils
pratiquent donc ça peut être le bla box
ou autre chose
lamont en l'occurrence c'est la boxe
donc un enfant qui est vraiment très
intéressé par la boxe qu'on peut avoir
moins de pression sur lui un enfant qui
fait ça comme il fait un autre comme il
pourrait faire notre sport là ça devient
du plus compliqué aussi être raisonnable
dire que c'est une histoire de carottes
aussi vous parler d'objectif tout à
l'heure sur sur les interrégions et sur
les prochains championnats régionaux de
benjamin notamment vous avez des espoirs
de titre là aussi bas sur le régional on
a un benjamin qui vient de passer
benjamin cette année ouais on va espérer
qu'ils soient champions quand même
d'autant plus à domicile ça ferait
plaisir
par contre au niveau interrégional
je vous cache pas que je pense que je
reviendrai ici dans très peu de temps
moi ou quelqu'un d'autre du club parce
qu'on risque d'avoir des champions de
france
l'année dernière on a été bloqué parce
que les benjamins ne participe pas aux
interrégions sauf que c'est benjamin qui
viennent avec des dents très aiguisé
sont les prochaines sont cette année en
minimes dont d'ailleurs d'eux qu'ils
reproduisent qu'ils étaient 20 ans
champion de france benjamins et qui sont
encore championne de france en minimes
et bien vous reviendrez sur le plateau
justement nous parler de leurs résultats
avec ben voilà on verra justement c'est
ce que vous avez annoncé est vrai si
l'on réussit merci à bon escient de la
soa la grâce ce wilfried ce week-end
l'entente sportive guyancourt toise de
gymnastique organisait les championnats
régionaux de gymnastique artistique
près de 350 gymnastes s'affrontaient
nous les avons suivis avec patrick
jacques de dixmude répétition grandeur
nature avant les championnats de france
les championnats régionaux de
gymnastique artistique organisée à
guyancourt ce week end permettent au
gymnase d'obtenir leur billet pour la
demi finale des championnats de france
la plupart des athlètes guyancourt toise
sont habitués aux joutes nationales
ce rendez vous est donc l'occasion
d'essayer de nouveaux enchaînements mais
parfois à risque
pour l'instant ça s'est bien passé mais
j'ai la seule nouveauté faut aller
jusqu'au bout des coeurs 20 gymnase lui
en courtois se préparent à cette
compétition depuis début août et le
stage de reprise et les performances
sont au rendez vous je suis content dans
l'ensemble parce qu'on a amené de
modifications par rapport au mouvement
de là d'après compétitions précédentes
dont il ya encore un peu d'incertitude
et de stress par rapport à ça mais dans
l'ensemble sur l'engagement il ya une
bonne chose bon quelques petites erreurs
sur ce premier agrès mais là on profite
du repos pour récupérer cette
compétition c'est aussi l'occasion de
faire naître des vocations
c'est beaucoup de stress pendant trois
jours son prêt par le vendredi on fait
tous le samedi ou le dimanche
mais ce qui est bien c'est que ça permet
de réunir les parents et les enfants que
des jeunes des futurs gym qui font de la
baby gym voir ce qu'elle pourrait faire
plus tard et puis se disent bien
pourquoi pas moi sur les deux jours de
compétition environ 350 participantes se
sont affrontés sur le plateau
trois gymnastes billancourt toison
remporté la compétition dans leurs
catégories respectives dont jade
pâtissons en nationale b elles
défendront leurs couleurs lors des
championnats de france au mois de mai et
le 7 août sport qui se poursuit après la
boxe éducative on va s'intéresser au
cyclisme à présent oui marraine en plus
avec jean bron pour se re non
exceptionnel
isabelle gautheron bonsoir à vous ancien
sextuple championne de france de
cyclisme sur piste
membre de la direction technique
nationale de la fédération française de
cyclisme et nouvelle marraine du
vélo-club d'elancourt de saint quentin
en yvelines
alors pourquoi avoir voulu devenir
marraine de ce club
pourquoi parce que ils ont un projet qui
est fort intéressant donc je les
connaissais pas avant le mois d'avril et
j'ai rencontré thierry fabre lors d'une
réunion concernant l'aménagement de la
pauline d'elancourt et puis on a discuté
et il m'a présenté son projet et il m'a
proposé d'être marraine et voilà j'ai
dis donc banque où on y va et surtout
aujourd'hui je suis directrice technique
nationale de la fédération
et comme je ne serai plus directrice
technique nationale au mois de mai
prochain
j'ai souhaité mettre fin à mes fonctions
eh bien je suis libre de tout engagement
et je peux aller dans le club qui me va
bien et je pense que et long cours est
un club qui qui a beaucoup d'avenir et
je pense qu'on peut faire des belles
choses ensemble
justement quand même la parenthèse
pourquoi vous quitter vos fonctions de
dtn je quitte parce que je suis
détiennent depuis huit ans j'ai fait
quatre ans sur le triathlon la quatre
ans sur le cyclisme c'est un métier très
dur enfin c'est une mission très très
dur voilà j'ai d'autres projets j'ai
d'autres projets qui aurait été
incompatible avec cette fonction et puis
bon
il ya un nouveau il va y avoir des
élections dans quinze jours à la
fédération
je pense que le président devrait être
réélu avec des nouveaux collaborateurs
et voilà donc je ne m'inscrirai pas dans
le projet de nouveau président enfin du
président qui sera nouvellement élu
peut-être la ville appartient voilà
sûrement david à partir ce que vous
pouvez apporter à ce club d'elancourt 50
ans des mines c'est votre attrait
évidemment pour la piste voilà j'espère
que je vais pouvoir leur apporter
beaucoup pour le développement de la
piste c'est quand même une discipline
très particulière on peut pas s'auto
proclamer pistard ou ou éducateurs sur
la piste sans avoir un minimum de
connaissances et voir de compétences
donc voila moi je veux être là pour être
au service pour essayer de développer
avec un projet un véritable projet pour
pourquoi pas venir
revenir ici après avec des titres de
champion d'île de france comme votre
votre invité de la boxe 1 il ya plein de
choses à faire autour du vélo avec un
outil comme celui ci on peut aussi
espérer avoir une équipe de niveau
national et pourquoi pas de niveau
international et vous aurez un superbe
outil de travail qui sera le vélodrome
tout près d'ici
alors un très bel outil de travail
j'étais encore dans les locaux la
semaine dernière pour une visite une
petite visite et voilà ça va être un
vélodrome de 250 mètres en bois des
virages afin là d'une largeur de 8
mètres ce qui n'existe pas aujourd'hui
c'est donc voilà je pense que ça va être
une piste un record et puis il y aura
vraiment tout pour accueillir les
cyclistes de façon optimale justement le
vélodrome c'est l'outil qui manque en ce
moment
dans le sport français surtout dans le
cyclisme français on va dire que oui
c'est un outil comme ça ça manquait même
si on avait un vélodrome à hyères c'est
mi couvert et un vélodrome couvert c'est
au bordeaux on va dire que c'est quand
même l'outil qui manquait aujourd'hui
les les athlètes s'entraînent sol insep
un petit vélodrome de 105,6 m donc vous
voyez les grandes compétitions se
déroulent sur 250 nettes
là on va avoir un bel outil ça n'a pas
empêché quand même d'avoir des champions
est encore aujourd'hui baugé centraide
nabot d'almeida donc ça va être un outil
complémentaire etc je crois que c'est la
piste j'avais dit dans un journal on
l'attend depuis 30 ans mais je crois que
ces mêmes depuis la destruction du vel
d'hiv qu'on attend un outil comme ça en
france
alors vous êtes la marraine du vélo-club
d'elancourt saint quentin en yvelines
j'ai l'impression c'est le seul club
dans les yvelines qui tient la route
les autres sont un peu en désuétude on
en a vingt mentions qui a que celui là
qui est vraiment qui sort encore du lot
alors c'est vrai que le vélo-club
d'elancourt a une particularité c'est
qu'il est il est affilié à trois
fédérations à l'ufolep à la fsgt et à la
ffv et donc il permet d'offrir un panel
d'activités beaucoup plus grandes que
les clubs qui reste sur une seule
fédération
donc je pense que c'est aussi pour ça
qu'il arrive à sortir du lot il sort du
lot aussi parce qu'il a quand même des
dirigeants très motivés qui encadre bien
leurs jeunes ça je crois que c'est très
important
le cyclisme est un sport individuel mais
qui se déroule par équipe est allée
faire du vélo tout seul ça va un temps
et donc si vous n'avez pas derrière une
dynamique et bien où vous changer de
club
ou alors vous arrêtez tout bonnement
après il ya le club de vélizy aussi
qu'un club quand même très dynamique
dans le département et puis on ad'autres
un petit peu plus loin sur lambert maul
mais s'attire à quoi ça tient à la
personnalité aux personnalités qui
dirigent les clubs aussi je pense que ça
tient ou personnalités on a on a le
comité départemental des yvelines donc
qui vient d'être renouvelé mais on peut
pas dire que ces dernières années ça a
été très dynamique
avant il y avait le tour des yvelines
qui marchait très bien qu'ils étaient
porteurs quand même comme événement sur
le territoire
voilà je crois que il faut que les
dirigeants du comité départemental et
que les dirigeants des clubs se
saisissent de ce vélodrome pour donner
une dynamique club est donné on a donné
envie aux jeunes de venir faire du fer
du cyclisme sur piste
vous croyez que le vélodrome justement
ça aide par exemple l'étape du tour de
france qui va démarrer versailles le
départ de paris nice dans quelques
semaines qui part de houille
ça aide c'est un vélo dans le
département voilà contre la livraison du
vélodrome le paris nice qui va partir
donc voilà le tour de france et vous le
rappeler anthony qui vient de se
dérouler aussi sur une partie sur les
yvelines du côté pas loin de saint
quentin en yvelines
c'est l'année du vélo il ya une vraie
dynamique aujourd'hui qui a enclenché je
crois qu'il ya une vraie dynamique qui a
été enclenché maintenant depuis deux ans
avec le départ du paris nice
quand même sur le département le tour de
france est aussi passé dans les yvelines
l'année dernière il est passé du côté de
de la vallée de chevreuse là il parle de
versailles
il refait tout un tour dans la vallée
donc
oui ça va donner encore plus de
consistance au projet vélo derrière
et oui c'est l'année du vélo en 2013 il
y aura un beau vélodrome et puis on va
dire que quand même le département des
yvelines et la vallée de chevreuse à
proximité c'est quand même le
département du vélo et puis cette
dernière étape donc du centième tour de
france qui passera notamment dans saint
quentin en yvelines à une vingtaine de
minutes à travers montini guyancourt et
on passera du côté du vélodrome vous le
verrez sur toutes les télés nationales
c'est vélodrome alors est-ce que
l'ancien sextuple championne de france
va devenir entraîneur en arrivant à
elancourt saint quentin en yvelines
l'entraîneur je sais pas si après avoir
été directrice technique j'ai envie
d'être entraîneur transmettre un savoir
oui mais de la joue sur les mots
entraîneur c'est presque ça maintenant
parce qu'un entraîneur et attention
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour mes
entraîneurs j'en ai quand même 25 dans
mon équipe
voilà maintenant est ce que j'aurai la
la patience d'être entraîneur parce que
c'est quand c'est un vrai métier je
pense peut-être dans moi je serais pour
l'instant je me positionne pas comme
entraîneur je me positionne plutôt comme
comme pas mener des projets ça fait pas
terrible mais le management
voilà comme une personne qui va essayer
de monter un projet avec des gens qui
sont déjà dans le club il ya des ya des
gens qui font beaucoup je suis pas là
pour prendre leur place je suis là pour
les aider pour les facilités aux
facilités voilà donc pas encore entraîné
au seuil sont appliquées en plus ils
viennent souvent sur ce plateau on les
suit depuis des années à un temps bien
sont exactement
merci beaucoup ils allaient être versés
menu ce soir sur le plateau de tv filet
puis on suivra donc l'évolution de ce
nouveau club avec sa nouvelle marraine
n'y a pas de problème merci mais si
cette édition du 7 8 sport qui se
poursuit en images à présent avec un
autre championnat régional cette fois ci
c'est du tennis de table
oui le club de voisins-le-bretonneux
accueillait pour la quatrième année le
tournoi régional l'occasion de voir
évoluer la crème des joueurs français
reportage avec patrick jacques de
dixmude les balles rebondissaient par
milliers sur les tables ce week end lors
du tournoi régional de
voisins-le-bretonneux et pour cause en
l'espace de quatre ans le tournoi vie si
noah a vu son nombre de participants
triplé passant de 100 à environ 300
joueurs venus de toute l'île de france
un succès qui permet d'attirer des
pointures tricolore comme alexis marc
haut de son neuvième joueur français il
a arrêté les compétitions individuelles
au niveau national mais garde le contact
avec les tournois
on peut par un match je montais en
national la semaine prochaine en par
équipes donc c'était pour pouvoir faire
des matches avant avant la semaine
prochaine
lobbies quand même aujourd'hui c'est de
gagner la compétition c'est le préparer
la semaine prochaine au sida
voir quelle forme ce week-end une
quarantaine de joueurs vicinaux à
défendre leur chance
parmi eux un droitier plutôt discret se
fait plaisir autour de la table on a dit
aujourd'hui donc dans le tout c'est
ribas et de me faire plaisir puisque je
jouais déjà fort que moi et dans le
tableau bas c'est d'arriver le plus loin
possible que j'ai joué des joueurs un
peu près à mon niveau ou un peu plus
fort et donc bas et saidal plus
impossible assis sur la chaise d'arbitré
entre ces matches anthony de luise
sortir a promis de sa poule mais jouera
en 8e de finale en revanche trois
joueurs vis chinois se sont hissés sur
le podium ce week end prochain rendez
vous la coupe de double des yvelines du
baseball à présent va parler de sport
américaine le japon le canada les plus
grande fédération internationale de
baseball lui font les yeux doux à 14 ans
mélissa mahieu et 12 des cougars de
montigny et surtout est considéré comme
le génie de sa discipline
nous sommes donc allés ça à sa rencontre
avec patrick jacques de dixmude après
j'ai grandi elle ne savait pas encore
lire que tenir là bas tu étais naturel à
14 ans mélissa mahieu collectionne les
titres de meilleure lanceuse et de mvp
meilleure joueuse du championnat
sélectionné en équipe de france de
softball et de baseball depuis un an
capitaine de son équipe aux cougars la
jeune minime et elle n'a pas atteint ce
niveau par hasard mélissa va essayer
d'apprendre le geste le plus
consciencieusement possible le répéter à
l'infini pour pouvoir s'améliorer
maintenant ce n'est plus sur une
globalité du jeu tales à apprendre c'est
sur des points de détail
et c'est pour ça qu'il lui faut des des
coaches qui soit du niveau national pour
pouvoir construire son jeu depuis
quelques mois les plus grandes
fédérations étrangères lui font les yeux
doux
en octobre dernier elle est invitée à
découvrir le baseball féminin japonais
dans quelques jours la lanceuse des
cougars va s'envoler pour cuba pour
participer à un stage avec la sélection
nationale canadienne en vue des
championnats du monde 2014
mais elle reste les pieds sur terre et
ne compte pas abandonner son club
formateur pour autant j'aimerais bien
pouvoir jouer jusqu'à 18 ans en france
et après pouvoir partir à l'étranger
dans une université et pouvoir faire
quelque chose dans des zones pour
l'instant je me débrouille ça arrivera
bien faire les dom et il ya des moments
où ça devient compliqué il faut pas se
louper des entraînements c'est comme une
école qui reste prioritaire
oh oui soissons son école on peut rien
faire
malheureusement pour le club saint
quentinois la réglementation ne permet
pas aux filles de jouer avec les garçons
après l'âge de 15 ans seul le softball
leur est ouvert mais mélissa a déjà fait
son choix continuer ma vie
l'essentiel des sports à présent avec
les autres résultats retenir de ce week
end rugby 13e journée de fédérale 3
plaisir s'est imposé à domicile 13 à 9
face au racing club les oies dans un
match plutôt fermé d'ailleurs avec un
seul essai inscrit par les plaisirs oies
les plaisirs roi du coup sont toujours
avec cette victoire
troisième de fédérale 3 égalité de
points avec vitry pourtant kobo lepers
et va devoir se battre néanmoins
jusqu'au bout pour obtenir son ticket
pour les playoffs handball avec les
féminines de montigny le bretonneux qui
allait un peu mieux ces dernières
semaines mais ça s'est pas confirmée
après trois défaites après trois
victoires par non consécutive un petit
coup d'arrêt pour les féminines de
montigny qui se sont inclinés sur le
terrain du sambre avesnois handball 30 à
malgré huit buts de la capitaine gabriel
par l'om avec cette défaite les joueuses
de stéphane paysans restent tout de même
à une jolie cinquième place de leur
poule de nationale 2 avec 28 points ce
qui est plutôt bon par rapport à
l'objectif de maintien effectivement
mais le podium semble maintenant
s'éloigner un petit peu plus il n'y aura
pas de surprises en tout cas cette année
sur ce championnat en basket pas de
surprise malheureusement cette fois ci
une fois de plus en plus tôt pour les
portera pour lever tout à fait un
championnat de france 1 de nationale 2
masculins nouvelle défaite pour les
toits les cheminots de trappes sur le
parquet de saint brieuc cette fois-ci 96
à 73
les joueurs trappistes sont toujours
dans la zone rouge mais ils ne sont plus
qu'à un point du premier non relégable
le mans
chez les femmes l'entente le chesnay
versailles traverse une période délicate
les filles de vinko bar dit se sont
inclinés à la glacerie 85 à 71 c'est
leur troisième défaite de la saison leur
mort
manque de profondeur de banc commence à
se faire sentir mais elles restent
leaders de leur poule de nationale 2 et
puis on en avait parlé
ça se resserre en tout de même au niveau
du classement ça devient japon d'avants
assez compliqué pour les féminines du
roller hockey aussi 10e journée de
nationale 3 après une petite pause
hivernale dirons nous les shops
d'elancourt se sont baladés
littéralement à sa gracieuse victoire 10
buts à 1 au terme d'un match très
maîtrisé surtout très rigoureux avec
très peu de pénalités encaissées
les joueurs de benjamin ferran sont
quatrièmes de leur poule et reste
meilleure défense du championnat avec 25
buts encaissés
et puis des nouvelles de tanguy de
lamotte tanguy de lamotte la dernière
dernière séquence nouvelles de notre
marin versailles et qui qui parcourt le
monde de dans le vendée globe ils ne
sont plus que 2 d'ailleurs en mer
alessandro di benedetto et le marin
tanguy de lamotte le marin versailles et
ces derniers jours le skipper
d'initiative coeur a percuté un ofni
résultat le safran tribord cassé et la
dérive très endommagée tanguy de lamotte
a dû réduire la lueur de son bateau à un
noeud c'est à dire quasiment rien du
tout sur place du sur place pour
permettre à la pompe électrique en fait
du bateau de vider l'eau du compartiment
que l'on voit d'ailleurs sur ces images
il a mis plusieurs jours à réparer
heureusement tout va bien pour lui
aujourd'hui tanguy est à moins de 1500
milles des sables d'olonne
il devrait retrouver la terre ferme
d'ici 3 à 4 jours vendredi ou samedi
j'ai voulu attendre l arrivée en plus
oui vas te retrouver à l'arrière est
tout à fait téléfilm se mobilisent
évidemment on sera présent à l'arrivée
du skippers d'initiatives coeur nous
recueillerons évidemment ses premières
réactions et des images exclusives que
vous verrez dans le prochain 7,8 sport
né le 7 8 sport de lundi prochain à ne
pas manquer 18h30 en direct pour voir
cette arrivée de tanguy de lamotte qui
est donc là tout proche des sables
d'olonne et puis on termine par une
bonne nouvelle en escrime will et des
nouvelles de jéromine et pas de langue à
vous savez c'est cette jeune tireuse du
club d'escrimé de trappes que nous
suivions en début de saison
la tiru junior vient de terminer
troisième à l'épreuve de coupe du monde
qui avait de mieux à lyon ce week end
avec cette performance jéromine rentrer
dans le top 10 mondial junior elle sera
dans quinze jours elle après l'ultime
étape à budapest si elle est
sélectionnée ou non pour les
championnats du monde juniors avec
l'équipe de france mais cela ne devrait
pas trop poser de problème merci entonné
on se retrouve donc la semaine prochaine
même heure pour un point complet sur
l'actualité sportive
mais n'hésitez pas à commenter le 7-8
sport sur les réseaux sociaux twitter et
facebook et nous donner tous les
résultats de vos clubs
à lundi prochain bonne soirée